das ist unsere
fragenlotterie mit scheinen mit fiesen fragen und
angenehmen fragen die roten sind
fies und die grünen sind wir oft wie
ihr euch aussuchen könnt seid ihr beide ein bisschen
durchgeknallt durchgeknallt ja ihr kennt eure
psyche ja ihr wisst die ganze zeit sicher
manchmal ich  Trink Redbull, nur damit ich
das Gefühl spüre, dass du jetzt Red Bull vergisst,
du weißt, wir können Schuhmarkt machen, er hat
das Neue, es ist wie Drogenmann, aber es sind
keine Drogen
wenn ich deutsch bin hallo psyched jetzt lächle ok
nächste frage davon heute hier drin ok es
scheint, dass du nicht wirklich auf deinen erfolg vorbereitet bist nicht wahr
also ja du
kannst dich nie vorbereiten wie würdest du wissen, wie
man sich in einer solchen situation verhält  Du warst noch
nie drin, es ist wie ich immer sage:
Wurdest du jemals von einem Hai gebissen, nein
, weißt du, wie du dich verhalten
wirst, wenn du von einem Hai gebissen wirst?
Ich weiß es nicht
genau, also wenn du sagst, Erfolg hatten
wir nie  d Erfolg bis jetzt, also
weiß ich nicht, wie es sich
verhalten wird, bevor ich es groß bekommen habe. Ja, Umkehrung, ok, die nächste
Frage ist eine gute, warum bist du so
talentiert,
ja, Joseph, warum bist du so müde?
Damit Sie sich weiterentwickeln müssen, müssen Sie
hart arbeiten. Uns wurden die Talente gegeben und
wir haben hart daran gearbeitet, also ist es eine
Kombination aus beidem. Ich würde sagen, ja, und
Sie haben fast 20 Jahre lang wirklich hart gearbeitet.
Ja, das haben wir
getan  die Zöpfe mit meinen Haaren werden
dünner ich werde immer älter frauen
also waren wir nicht schwer ok ok sache nette
frage ok ist es nicht sehr schwierig in
norwegen an drogen zu kommen ernsthafte stunden bitte
ich wüsste nicht deswegen nehme ich eine  viel
zu beantworten, weil ich wirklich nicht so
gut weiß wie jemand, der tut, was du versuchst,
mich auszutricksen. Ja, ich weiß das nicht von
Papa Battier-Musikern
weiß nicht ich weiß es ist
einfach Bier wodka die drogen ich weiß nicht
das s  tuff ok hey ich bin auf keinen fall drogen
ich glaube nicht das es keine
drogen gibt nein okay nette frage
ok
wow das ist interessant dass diese
frage kommt absolut was dein
erfolg glühen würde wirklich nur das
ergebnis harter arbeit oder war es das  nur die
Präsenz der edu edu European
Broadcasting Union der Hintergrund ist es
der Hintergrund ist es war eine große Chance
für Sie ja nun, Sie wissen, es besteht kein
Zweifel, dass der Eurovision-Wettbewerb eine
großartige Arbeit für uns war, aber es ist auch ein
hartes Ergebnis  Arbeit keine Möglichkeit hineinzukommen und
wie man es bekommt und als sie unsere
Version davon hörten, was wir dort tun wollten,
als wir ihr Schicksal präsentierten, kennst du
manchmal das Universum, das du damit aufhörst
, wenn ich die ganze Zeit rede,
manchmal das Universum  kommt zusammen
und die Energie stimmt überein,
also bin ich das.
Ich kann das fühlen. Ich habe eine Frage an
Sie. Sie haben das Lied vorgestellt, das und
mehrere andere dasselbe tun. Ja, und Sie
gewinnen. Sie können sagen, dass es eher
so war, als ob es einen Wettbewerb gab  Sinn und die  Sie haben
vielen Hot Shots den Dreh gegeben und
sie fühlten, dass wir die richtigen
Botschafter waren, wie zum Beispiel Star Gate,
eines der
größten Produktionsteams der Welt, die Welt, die ich
nicht verstehe, und wenn Celine Dion
genau produziert  Ja, und sie fühlten, dass
wir die richtigen Botschafter sind, um zu
repräsentieren, dass Sie diese Einheit kennen, diese
Positivität für diese ein bisschen, also
das Wort Grund vor dem Grand
Prix für Sie, ja, mehr oder weniger die gute
Art, es auszudrücken, das ist nicht in Ordnung für Sie
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, Lancashire, ok, was ist
mit japanischen Fragen, bei denen alle Leute
an uns denken? Also, was ist die
Frage, du brauchst keine Drogen, um
stoned zu sein, richtig, du bist irgendwie natürlich,
sie stellen kein Leben ein, mein Mann, du siehst, ein
Leben ist  guten Nachglühen ist der
Eurovision nach Deutschland gekommen uns geht es
sehr gut höheres Leben muss nicht
gestoppt werden du musst nicht gestoppt werden ok noch
eine letzte frage rot oder grün rot rot
versuche
ok denkst du norwegen ist ein richtiges
land  Sex haben  Beziehungen ohne
Schutz Ich weiß, das ist nicht richtig. Ich
kenne die Frage. Glaubst du, es gibt
ein Pufferland, um ein Superstar zu werden?
Ja, ich denke, jedes Land ist ein gutes
Land, um ein Superstar zu werden
nannte diesen jungen Klumpen, was ich nicht
weiß, okay, das sind sie auf keinen Fall,
wo alle gleich sind,
niemand über jedem steht, was bedeutet, dass,
egal wie groß du wirst, du sehen kannst, wie
unsere Ha auf den Straßen läuft, die
du sehen kannst  Wer auch immer auf der
Straße geht, Michael Jackson Oh wa wa wa,
du wirst ihn zwar nicht sehen, aber die Leute werden
ihn beobachten, sie sehen ihn an, aber
hier ist es nicht so, dass er Leibwächter braucht
und Leute, die ihn
überfahren können  Gehen Sie nicht auf die Straße, Sie
haben das nicht im Weg, also wissen wir,
wo ich denke, dass es ein guter Ort für uns ist
, um geerdet zu bleiben und in die
Welt hinauszukommen, und Sie haben keinen Erfolg, es ist
schön, aber nicht wahr  einfacher sein,
es wäre einfacher, ja  Ich glaube nicht, dass
es einfacher ist, in den Staaten Erfolg zu haben,
aber du wirst viel größer, ja
, das macht dein Leben einfach,
also willst du gehen, er will ungefähr zwei
Staaten, wir sehen uns. Nun, das
ist eigentlich nur so  in ein oder zwei monaten okay
weißt du wir waren dort wir wurden
wirklich entlassen in den staaten haben
wir dort gearbeitet also ja daumen hoch
daumen hoch daumen ganz nah die finger
liebe alle wie lange okay danke
sehr danke
und viel Glück keine Küche
Sie